y es el momento de hablar de las
noticias de la salud y para ello me
acompaña mar Romero sala Buen día para
ustedmar Buenos días Ángela Bueno vamos
a empezar hablando de una noticia en
España que confirmó Omar que un paciente
que se creía que podía estar contagiado
con el virus de marburgo Finalmente no
tiene esa enfermedad si ha sido después
de pasar varios días confinados al igual
que el personal sanitario que lo había
tratado se sospechaba de que podía estar
contagiado de este virus porque venía de
Guinea ecuatorial que es el país donde
actualmente hay un brote que ya se ha
cobrado nueve vidas desde el inicio del
año para aclarar estas dudas para
entender mejor de qué estamos hablando
estamos con Óscar Franco que es director
del departamento de salud pública de la
Universidad de utreck doctor muy buenos
días y empecemos por el principio de qué
se trata este virus
Buenos días Este es un virus que es de
la misma familia que el virus del ébola
tiene bastante semejanzas con este virus
es un virus que fue detectado por
primera vez en 1967 en Europa debido a
un accidente que ocurrió en un
laboratorio y es una zoonosis lo que
quiere decir que es una infección que
viene de los animales y que puede pasar
al ser humano es la forma primaria en
Cómo se puede contagiar y viene
Generalmente de los murciélagos que se
alimentan de frutas Entonces cuando
entra el ser humano en contacto con
fluidos o con heces de estos murciélagos
Puede ocurrir la infección Bueno
entonces no sorprende a doctor y buen
día para usted el temor porque pudiera
llegar este virus a España los síntomas
se parecen mucho al ébola y a otras
enfermedades tropicales como Entonces se
pueden distinguir
Buenos días Ángela sí los síntomas son
muy parecidos es muy difícil de
distinguir empieza como como una gripe
como un virus como cualquier otro virus
con decaimiento con malestar general con
algo de fiebre y luego Pasa unas fases
más avanzadas donde hay compromiso
gastrointestinal compromiso de órganos y
luego la fase hemorrágica es muy
parecido la única forma es tomar las
muestras confirmarlas en laboratorio
hacer el pcr necesario O la información
recoger la información necesaria y es
muy importante estar en alerta porque
son enfermedades que tienen una
letalidad muy alta entonces hay que
aislar el caso y las personas quieren
han estado en contacto con el caso de la
manera más corta posible precisamente
tomar muestra de algo que es
especialmente difícil en las zonas donde
más serán estos brotes que son en las
zonas subsaharianas de África pero
queríamos preguntarle qué tan contagiosa
es esta enfermedad No qué riesgo hay
para otras regiones de que se llegue a
extender Más allá de Guinea ecuatorial
en este caso
hay que poner todo dentro del marco de
la perspectiva también del virus y la
perspectiva histórica Si vemos desde
1967 no tenemos más de 500 casos en
total registrados de este virus de
marburgo Entonces estamos hablando de
una infección que que sí tiene una
letalidad alta pero que su nivel de de
contagio no es demasiado alto
generalmente se puede presentar en otras
regiones cuando hay personas que viajan
de las zonas afectadas a las regiones
donde se podría donde se podría ocurrir
la nueva transmisión pero Generalmente
Esto no se ha visto de una manera muy
frecuente en toda la historia de este
virus en particular bueno pese a ello
doctor nos preguntamos si es un virus de
tanta letalidad porque hay tan poca
investigación a su alrededor
Sí es muy difícil porque Generalmente no
se presentan muchos casos son brotes que
son se confinan a una sola ubicación
geográfica o número limitado de de
pacientes también hay un aspecto
cultural que está el hecho de que muchas
personas ven con muchas sospecha en los
procesos de vacunación y localmente en
África se ha rechazado mucho estas
enfermedades como enfermedades que tal
vez se han inventado o que sean o que se
han montado hay mucha teoría de
Conspiración entonces a veces hay una
combinación de Estos factores y por otro
lado está que pues el mercado no es
demasiado grande por como para que las
compañías farmacéuticas hagan una gran
inversión en esta investigación sin
embargo Sí hay algunas investigaciones
que están en marcha no había algunas
vacunas experimentales queríamos
preguntarle si no se debería estar
aprovechando el brote actual que está
sucediendo en este momento para poder
probar todas estas terapias o
tratamientos o vacunas que no existen
todavía porque no se han podido
demostrar tampoco su eficacia
Así es de hecho el primer reporte que se
hace acerca de una de un de una vacuna
para este tipo de virus En fase uno sale
este año a finales de enero es muy
difícil por ese número de casos que está
tan limitado deberíamos aprovechar o se
vería aprovechar la situación que se
está viviendo en este momento para poder
investigar pero los casos no son muy
altos hay nueve muertes reportadas 16
casos sospechosos Entonces los niveles
de de casos que pueden estar disponibles
sobre la población que pudiera ser
disponible para hacer estudios ya de
fase dos o fase tres son muy limitados
Para poder proceder
Bueno pues muchísimas gracias a usted
doctor Gracias mar por traernos esta
información y ayudarnos a resolver las
dudas sobre este virus y nos vemos
mañana nos vemos mañana Ángela